MSRP is transformative just the fact of
coming to MIT and realizing that oh I'm
smart I can actually get in here I've
wanted to come to MIT for a very long
time since I was a little kid let go end
up with it's just an intense experience
it's an amazing community where everyone
is really passionate about what they're
doing that environment has been
incredible for me this summer
this summer I'm working at the
biological engineering department and
developing biomaterials for the liver I
worked on the characterization of alloys
created in dr. Michael shorts lab we're
looking at ways of using renewable
energy and one way of doing that is
making cells produce fuels for us my
project seeks to use Google glass to
actually capture information you've lost
and bring it to you on demand how is the
app gonna know when you've found what
you were trying to find okay I found it
BAM like let's stop they don't back to
president yet I've located 2-0 at that
time and I put the red sphere there
we're doing visualization of
electromagnetic fields we're trying to
visualize the field lines of a swinging
magnetic dipole what I like about
physics is that anything you have you
can explain in a way or another with
physics I like that there's always
something more to discover I feel like
we're never gonna know everything as
soon as I got here and I got into this
environment what everybody had this
awesome ideas it inspired me and it got
me to ink in different ways whatever the
units of tea or I've got 360 units of
tea dr. Becher is very supportive every
time I have a question he's there to
answer me
she's great because I tell her to go off
and figure out how github works and she
goes off and fingers hound get hub work
he knows a lot about writing code but
he's not really good with the software
so I become an expert on controlling the
saw point
I need people like Casey who can
actually go out and do stuff we have
contact with the faculty members that we
talk with for our faculty presentations
every Tuesday morning we curse and
faculty paper that we had gotten the
previous week what happens after the
verifier generates those W values it
allows us to communicate more
effectively and open our minds up it
brings about a more diverse
iron man after we finish the paper a
faculty professor come to clarify maybe
some questions about the research we
didn't know and also to talk about their
life I actually the faculty mentor of
the rocket team they are doing
fascinating stuff I think it's to get us
in that mindset that you know grad
school is gonna be hard all of these
people went through really hard times to
get to where they are now and you should
be expecting the same thing especially
if you want to go somewhere like MIT
MSRP is really grad school oriented they
help us to prepare for the GRE test
we've started writing our abstracts for
projects they also help you write the
statement of purpose which is a
requirement for most PhD programs or
even masters the whole research part is
kind of a small version of grad school
too
the coolest thing about MIT to me is
that there's lots of art all over the
place in front of one of the domes
there's sculptures and structures
there's lots of cool architecture being
alone and exploring it gave me like a
new sense of adventure
there are certain times of day where you
can walk up to the McCormick Hall where
we're living and go in the kitchen and
you just see all your friends there
talking sometimes dinner hours 12 o
clock for 8:00 and the mornings you
won't see anyone there everyone's
sleeping the acapella groups here the
names are so cute the glasses there's so
we also have a social component in the
program so we'll take a trip to Martha's
Vineyard just relax
to forget the stress of the research and
everything it's a very beautiful place
and the people you need in this program
they're so amazing
they come from so many different
backgrounds and I've made some really
good friends there's just really great
day that I'm assertive it's together
it's called community service day in
research what we are doing is helping to
the community to discover new things new
benefit things for the society
volunteering is the same thing you're
helping the community it's about doing
big breakthroughs in science to help
humanity this program has made me grown
a lot in every way personally
academically professionally MSRP has
really made me more sure of myself that
I want to pursue graduate school it's
just given me more confidence that I can
accomplish that I am having a totally
awesome summer here I had great
expectations and they have been met it
was intense and I loved it